transport secretary grant shops is
joining us now mr chaps a very good
morning
to um all change again uh however france
saying it's entering a fourth
wave in the south of the country with
emergency measures
in place how anxious are you about that
yeah i mean france uh suffering from the
delta variant which we've obviously
been through and they are now going
through themselves but um
uh you know i'm very pleased that we've
got a situation now where
france is normalized in terms of being
able to be treated like all other
amber countries meaning people can come
back and they don't have to
self-isolate having been to france it's
just the day two test
uh that's still required and a test
before they leave france
how anxious are you about this fourth
wave in france though they've put as i
said emergency measures in place
yes i say i think france um and actually
much of the continent
um are experiencing the same delta wave
that we went through of course
and um and we know how this plays out
and the more vaccinated you are the
better off
uh you are and the french vaccination
numbers and indeed across europe
have now started to catch up uh with
more people being vaccinated more people
will be
protected so um look i think we'll
always have to keep i'm afraid we'll
always have to keep a close eye on this
virus but today
is really good news with um france
opening up to people
um several countries moving to the uh
green list and indeed countries coming
off the red list including uh india
qatar
the uae and bahrain and so more travel
during the summer and these are the
changes which uh exist
um we hope throughout august so there
aren't any changes next week or the week
after
people we hope will enjoy their holidays
you don't know that though do
you um given what's happening in france
and other parts of europe and given
that uh we've scrapped the amber plus
and this
amber watch list france and other
countries could go
straight back on the red list well look
at
i suppose with the virus it's always the
case that um
you have to be keeping a very close and
vigilant eye out i mean we've known that
the whole way through this
but uh we know a lot more about the
virus now than we did say this time last
year
uh everyone um has been offered a
vaccine uh now and that's obviously the
big game changer
uh and uh throughout europe and the rest
of the world the
number of vaccines are catching up as
well all of which provides a sort of
wall of protection
and look we know um that people look
forward to save up for
and want to go on holiday plus other
people who are traveling to see family
and friends
or just to do business and we want to
try and make it as straightforward
as possible and that's what the changes
do as we gradually move from our
domestic unlock
to being able to internationally unlock
as well
so there's no chance of spain france
going straight back onto the red list
well i think you know that you can with
coronavirus you can never say
zero chance with coronavirus but having
said that
the levels of vaccination and what we
now know about the
virus and what our scientists have been
able to work out in the last year
means that people should be able to go
away enjoy their holidays without
looking over their
shoulders the whole time and as i say
the next set of changes are not for
another three weeks
people thought that when they went to
portugal though didn't they and then
they had to rush back and
previously august of last year it was
the same situation
in france as well but you're pretty
confident
that uh the countries like spain i'm
choosing spain and france because that's
where most brits go
on holiday in europe um they were are
very unlikely to go back onto the red
list this summer well
i i remember this well not least because
i put from
spain on the um on the off the travel
corridor as it was at the time and
and came home myself to start myself
isolation so i understand the impact
that this has
on people the big difference this year
uh the game changes vaccinations
and that means sorry transport secretary
but we had we had the vaccinations with
portugal didn't we and that still moved
very quickly
not not really and not to this extent
the the difference now of course is that
you know every person in in the uk over
18 has been offered a vaccination
vast proportion of the population uh
we're coming up to 90 percent of first
vaccinations done
over 70 percent of second vaccinations
possible portions of the population got
it here
but also and importantly also in these
destination countries particularly in
europe
who started off if you recall very
slowly on the vaccination program
but are now catching up and that again
you know means you've got protection
both sides
of the of that travel i want to know
about your advice on these
pcr tests um that you need to take
that you're advised to take before you
come back to the uk they're not
compulsory
so why would a family of four
potentially spend
an extra six seven hundred pounds when
they don't need to
so just to clarify there's no change in
terms of
uh what's required so we've always had
quite a high specification it's called
sensitivity and specificity it's called
uh for the tests that you have to do
before you come to the uk
and that specification has not changed
in the case of spain
uh where we have a uh an interest in a
variant called the b1621 variant um
the the the reality is that uh nine out
of ten people already take a pcr test so
there is actually
uh no uh particular change pcr tests are
helpful
because it will help our clinicians and
our scientists work together
uh to keep a very close eye on on
variants and so it's just a reminder
that those tests are particularly useful
but if they're not compulsory why should
people invest in a pcr test rather than
a lateral flow test
yeah it's i mean say nothing's actually
changed we've always asked people to go
and get a test question remaining
they're the same though sir
why why would they well say they've
already actually been required to get a
test of
this particular of a high sensitivity
and specificity that hasn't changed
uh it's just a reminder of the pcr ones
if you have the choice if you're
if you're presented with both the pcr
ones are particularly useful as i say in
spain
uh it so happens that actually the pcr
test is the go-to test
um it's actually it gets quite technical
but it's quite unusual
to find a lateral flow test which
actually meets the
requirements it so happens the uk
lateral flow tests are of high
specification
but in most places including spain
people are already getting the
appropriate type of test
we're just reminding people that helps
our scientists to
sequence the genome which is the thing
which enables us to know whether there
are variants so it's a useful addition
less than three percent of tests are
actually used uh as far as the genome is
concerned to find out what's going on
uh with variants but the uh nhs
in this country use the lateral flow
test so surely that's that's good enough
isn't it
uh so i think there you're referring to
nhs workers who
are taking actual flow tests in order to
be able to uh
work the specific issue here is
when we're looking at people who've been
abroad we're actually interested in
particularly in variants of concern
rather than just whether they have um
coronavirus that's the thing we want to
most track
because we already have coronavirus here
what we're interested in is anything
which we don't have here
uh at number already so that that's why
we require quite a high specification
for that test
so there's no actual change here i've
seen quite a lot of coverage about it
this morning there's no actual change
here we're just reminding people that a
pcr test does enable
our scientists to track uh any changes
and our clinicians and scientists are
working with the spanish authorities
uh to make sure they keep it closer if
that is monitored and only on three
percent of
um genome testing uh from the from the
pcr tests are
done at this stage is what we're being
told but i'm just clarifying for my
viewers they don't need to spend that
extra 500 quid
unless they absolutely want to if
they're a family of four um
let me ask you about uh 12 to 15 year
olds uh being jabbed when we when are we
going to hear about that
well we've always as you know we've got
the joint
committee on vaccines and immunizations
the jcvi and they're the ones right from
the outset who
approved the different ages and we came
down through the age categories
and they've now got down to saying 16
and 17 year olds
can and should be vaccinated
and they'll carry on looking at the data
and we'll have to wait for them to come
back so the simple answer to your
question is
we'll wait for the experts from the jcvi
to tell us when it's safe
and uh and uh and they feel appropriate
to
vaccinate people going down the age
ranges i think your twins are about that
age aren't they would you be happy for
them to be vaccinated
yes yeah absolutely and uh you know
and they're very keen to be um
vaccinated as well they're in that age
group the 16 17 age group
and it's amazing particularly towards
the end of term how many of their
friends
uh had coronavirus and how much time
that they had to spend off school
at home because of um needing you know
bubbles being sent home and what have
you
so they understand the the disruption
and the amount of their own lives
um and their own schooling that's been
affected by this in the very very key
and i'm at the other end of this
spectrum um when can i expect
to be able to have my booster jab well
again the jcbi will say more about this
but um the the
expectation is that along with you know
the annual
flu jab um anyone over 50 uh would
also most likely be asked to come
forward for a sort of top up on the
uh on the copa jab as well so that's the
the the likely plan at the moment come
the autumn
but again we'll wait for the scientific
experts to tell us exactly what they
want us to do and when
why have you opened dubai um as part of
the
uh travel corridor is that pandering to
the travel industry so that
it can be used as a hub for the rest of
the world to come into the uk
no i mean with all these changes uh i i
often see as
a whole load of theories behind why a
particular country has been opened or
another one hasn't but actually with all
these changes what we do is ask
the experts that's the joint biosecurity
center the jbc in this case
to give us their uh overview of every
country and their recommendation about
where a country should sit um this time
they've come back and they've said
um dubai and qatar the uae
and in fact india which will surprise
some people
are all fit to come from the red list
and come on to the
uh ambulance and it will be the usual
combination of
you know level of prevalence of of
coronavirus the number of people who've
had their
injections already how good the data is
how much
how much sequencing goes on so we can
look for these variants so it'll be the
same factors apply everywhere else
um just before i let you go a lot of
holiday virtue signaling from your
colleagues in cabinet at the moment are
you planning to
stay in a yurt in yorkshire this year
are you going to holiday overseas
we haven't yet had the discussion in the
in the chaps household i was actually
like everybody else
waiting for this set of uh
traffic light announcements before we
had the discussion because like everyone
else i was waiting to get the experts
advice as to where we can uh i can go i
suspect it might be a conversation
in our household this coming weekend
what's wrong with yorkshire
nothing love love the auction um but uh
where where are you going
where am i going i'm uh staying in the
cotswolds this summer
i was hoping to go to africa but you've
left it on the red list so i'm not
sorry about that yeah don't think you
are but thank you anyway
thank you appreciate you taking the time
thank you